what is happening man
hi rich how are you doing good
uh first of all thank you very much for
all your content and guidance really
love it
um
i just wanted to ask you about you know
uh i remember you mentioned in one video
that
uh initially like a long time time ago
you were in a relationship and and you
know you were in a situation where you
were spending a lot of time uh you know
on the phone
and uh that's something obviously that
uh are you married though because you're
because you're coming
okay married guy okay good man
so and and you said that you know
obviously that that damages the
attraction you know you're spending so
much time talking to a woman and
so in the long-term uh relationship
we're in the marriage obviously you have
to carry a conversation to some extent
so what is that degree how do you carry
on a conversation how do you maintain
attraction
at the same time not undervalue yourself
yeah i got it so that's going to depend
on quite a few things actually because i
mean
um
you could
cut back the amount of time
like let's say that you travel a lot and
you're on the phone a lot like under
under what context are you spending so
much time on the phone
well right now i'm i'm living away from
from from my family i'm in canada
they're abroad okay uh so so that's now
obviously there's the time difference
aspect there as well but i'm i'm working
full-time so that kind of uh you have
kids you know limits i have kids yes
three kids okay
so
like do you see them every three months
like you travel back and forth to see
them or how does that work
uh yeah i travel back and forth they're
going to be visiting me they're going to
be
you know coming back as well
but uh right now i mean they're you know
we're we're gonna be apart for until
probably the end of november so for a
few months how often do you guys talk
like you know you're on a skype or
facetime like is that what your users on
a phone
it's a phone daily or on whatsapp or on
whatsapp video chat but we do it
basically and how long is it
well usually um you know i'll do it
maybe about an hour every night and you
talk to the kids
uh yeah bedtime i'll do the bedtime in
the morning how much time do you talk to
kids for uh how much time you talk to
always for
uh well usually it's like on the same
call you know so the kids will will
chime in and so i'll do a couple of
minutes with them then with the wife and
talking about school and
then talking with the kids for a little
bit so it's just back and forth you know
okay and you should like talking about
family stuff like you know pro like
productivity issues you know with the
kids stuff that's going on you know with
relatives or is it just like
you know i watched the show and the
bachelor and somebody got voted off the
island like what are you talking about
no it's usually sometimes with the
relatives you know sometimes uh it's
usually it's about the kids usually it's
about stuff that's going on in our house
you know things that need to be done
you know things that we have on our
to-do list you know just you know going
over them
um but not rarely do we ever talk about
you know entertainment or tv it's very
rare
all right but
there is one thing there is one thing
with her issues with her in her
relationships so sometimes i have to be
uh you know like rolo was saying you
know if you're if you're talking to a
woman and you're talking to her in a way
that's
feminine then you become her girlfriend
so i'm very i'm very conscious of that
you know i
i don't want to be somebody where and
she's mentioned that that sometimes i'm
not
you know
being a good sound board but at the same
time i don't want to come across this
you know it's feminine well
okay so that's a good point so
like women have girlfriends and
boyfriends obviously right
girlfriend she's gonna get together and
have a little drink and you know talk
about [ __ ] like you know being a parent
and a mother and raising kids and the
stupid [ __ ] that they have to put up
with right and they're probably going to
complain a little bit about other things
as well
let
like encourage her to have time with
women for stuff like that deal with the
look we have a family we have kids i
want to make sure they're fed you know
they do in their school work like you
know whatever's important to you
and then whatever is important to the
relationship and then that's it right
but i mean like you don't want to get
into a long drawn out two or three hour
conversation on a on a video call every
day of the week i mean i'm assuming you
have other things to do as well but i
mean you're still a married guy you're a
family guy you have small children
raised it sounds like they're young
still
they're very young yeah my oldest is
seven yeah well you want to have a good
relationship with that right because i
mean that's you know those are the
formative years so
give the kids the time they need give
her the time that she needs but you have
to judge when to end it right if it's
like okay
this is not a good useful conversation
for either one of us then right you're
the guy you know what sweetheart love
you to bits i gotta run i gotta do this
or i have to you know complete this task
or whatever you know
and that's it and i'll you know i look
forward to seeing you tomorrow love you
good night boom right that's it
and then just one last question what
would you say about you know keeping
conversations uh
keeping them you know keeping the spice
in the conversations like in you know
the initial days obviously it's very
romantic and you know there's a lot of
genuine burning desire but as the
conversations you know when you're in a
long-term marriage they're very dry how
often
how often do you see your family
uh well lately it's been quite a lot
it's usually every two months okay so
two months is good so you see your wife
for a little bit you see the kids you
know for the two months and you come
back okay enough right yeah so i mean
like you've got like remember it's going
to be full time
yeah so you're in an interesting
long-term sorry long-distance
long-term relationship because you're
married right you're doing this for work
but you still get to see her so i mean
there's still the intimacy you still get
to be with her you still get to play and
you know see the kids just just keep it
spicy man you know just throw a little
spice in there you know
i don't know you know what you're you
know what your culture you know is going
to limit you to but
you know be as creative as you want like
you know she's your wife right like you
know sex is the glue that holds the
marriage together sort of thing right
make sure that lots of that is going on
you know whatever you feel comfortable
with
got it thank you so much it doesn't have
to be every single call but at least
like hey look you know
whatever it happens to be but it better
you know just just tell her you know
what it just better put a smile on my
face when i open up my phone
you got it okay you know what i'm saying
sounds good i appreciate it yeah thank
you for play around with it okay man
sorry thank you
you